elles ont marché en silence ce matin
dans les rues de la ville plus de 250
personnes sont venues rendre un dernier
hommage ameline deux ans tué il ya dix
jours en tête de cortège la maman et la
grand-mère de la fillette entourés de
leurs proches mais aussi de beaucoup
d'anonymes
ça me touche
la moins de cette petite quoi moi là
c'est pour ça que je suis ému c'est
normal que je mets en doute magie on
vient entendre par an elle ne soutenir
pour un dernier voyage de la petite
maligne parce que ça nous a tous
un soutien des habitants de la ville et
de ses environs qui a ému la famille
je suis extrêmement touché parce que ma
petite fille et ne méritait tellement
c'était la joie de vivre c'est un amour
et je sais que si son nom dernier cadeau
que je lui fais tout ce que maintenant
je peux la fin pour elle
madame vous êtes la grand-mère quel est
le message que vous avez souhaité aussi
faire passer par cette marche
plus jamais plus jamais on n'a pas le
droit de faire ça à un enfant t'as pas
le droit de faire ça une maman absente
de la région la maire de la ville était
représentée par ses adjoints désireux
d'accompagner la famille dans sa peine
je ne dirais qu'une chose
plus jamais ça je pense que c'est cette
atroce
et puis j'aimais ça ça veut dire aussi
comment est-ce qu'on peut éviter ça et
bien je pense qu'il faudra
je vais pas parler d' exemple mais il
faudra que la justice on en compte quand
même certaines situations et régis au
plus vite le père de méline qui s'est
accusé du meurtre a été mis en examen la
semaine dernière il est actuellement
incarcéré à la maison d'arrêt de dijon